hey there Knight commanders I'm Clara
babylegs what's up everyone I'm Bosch
reverse and we're here to show you my
top tips and tricks for leveling up in
knights and Dragons your kingdom calls
tip number one be efficient when your
health is run low in the battlefields
join the area to try and level up so you
can get right back out there or you can
just play in the arena all the time like
somebody I know
haha guy with Duke thing and these are
some you know these aren't fingers at
all why did I have to get technical
these are thumbs these are technically
fingers tip number two bust out the
special move extra loot Shelby moves
brown the last tip to kill when battling
a boss make sure to use your special
move for extra treasure not to mention
you look awesome use your special move
turn around and enjoy the spoils of war
tip number three score free gems if you
don't have the money to purchase gems
all you have to do is watch a few ads
and you'll get some for free they're
really not that bad just watch an ad you
get free gems it's free you don't pay
nothing you watch you get the Freak it's
awesome pretty simple tip number four
level up your armor wisely don't waste
time or goals leveling up armor that
isn't fluffs level rated forget about it
tip number five make it a habit log in
every day brothers log in every day for
extra rewards and gold every
dang you get free stuff just login every
day never keep laughing log in every day
tip number six balance your elements
make sure that the nights that you bring
into battle with you are the opposite
element of whatever boss and/or monster
you're fighting wanna bring in some
fireman earth bring in some air part
spirit go planet who is that that's the
ring this is my friendship where I come
from